A common way to distribute tabular data is in a
data format called CSV. Even if you're already familiar with
CSV, stay with us because in just a few minutes,
we'll look at using the CSV module in Python to make
it much easier to work with this type of data.
As you can see in this example, this is the
same discography data we looked at in a spreadsheet The
only difference here is the format. In this case we're looking
at in CSV. Here you can see the first line of the file contains the labels for
all of the fields. Let's take a look at
an individual item here. Here we have an individual
item in this data set. A Hard Day's Night
is the single released on June 26th, 1964. And
while it looks like this particular item appears on
two lines of text, it's really just one line,
my window simply isn't wide enough to show
the entire line visually on a single line. So
one of the principal reasons why CSV is so
widely used is because it's very lightweight. Each line
of text is a single row, fields are
separated by a delimiter, usually a comma, but we
can also have an alternate of CSV, called TSV,
where the delimeter is tab characters. CSV files really
store just the data itself, or just the data and
the delimeters. The benefit of this is that the files
are as small as they reasonably can be. Another nice
feature is that we don't need any special purpose software. We
don't need, for example, Microsoft Excel in order to load
CSV files. We can look at CSV files using a
command line editor as we just saw an example, or
even the very simplest text editors. It's also the case that
it's easy to write programs that read in CSV
data, in just about any programming language. Finally, though
we don't need a spreadsheet application in order to
read and write CSV, any spreadsheet app will be able
to work with CSV files. Now what I'd like you to do is choose a tool of your
choice, download the provided file, see the instructors comments
for the links. And then look at the CSV file
you've downloaded in some text editor.